having a teenager and a newborn at the
same time has got to be like
a wild time as a parent
we'll see those are supposedly like the
hardest
[Music]
hello welcome back to big mood everybody
we are in a brand new set yeah missing
one of our core members yeah but who is
here i'm nikki i'm tiff and jess and we
are missing gina cocina
we are missing her even though we are
filming in her house yes
she's she's like in the next room
honestly after jess and i both flew in
from other states last night yep uh we
came to we came to the set and like five
minutes before we showed up which none
of us got a text for or we just didn't
know uh we found out that gina got a
text saying that someone she worked with
had tested positive for omicron and uh
so we were like okay what do we do and
she's just been quarantining her own
room in her own room she doesn't come
here across the hall with the mask on if
if we do see her face yeah and she can't
get tested right now because they're all
at a shortage for tess so yeah we don't
know if she has it or not yeah we're
going to be completely safe and negative
but we don't know she's getting
fine but yeah we have we have a pregnant
lady here yeah she's sitting out of our
episode today i actually got
omicron myself in december how was it
because you haven't had any of that i i
was like the person on instagram talking
about how it could be for two years did
you feel left out did you feel kind of
like no i look like i'm better than all
of y'all
i have superior you're the chosen one
yeah i'm the chosen one i have superior
genes um my pfizer it uh expired exactly
as the cdc said it was and i immediately
got omicron like on my seventh month at
post vaccination so i was like [ __ ] i
was kind of getting to the point where i
was like do they even know what they're
talking about i don't know
what they're talking about and then uh
yeah no i was like i'm not gonna get
boosted if omicron is lighter i'll just
get it naturally and then i was honestly
very much regretting it as i was so sick
for those two weeks so don't recommend
doing that i would recommend getting the
universe just like careful what you wish
i think you're strong [ __ ] you're about
to cry for two weeks
um but yeah now i've i'm fully recovered
now i'm on like day 20 and my sense of
smell came back i'm still coughing a
little bit still sniffling a little bit
but my energy's back good i don't think
i have the brain fog but i you know you
know you don't really know when you're
kind of slow or dumb so we'll see
i i feel like uh i feel like having code
last year or i guess two years ago
because it's not twenty years before it
even yeah
no no that was till i was in 19 but yeah
you had that one too right 2020 was now
two years ago yeah yeah yeah no there
was in 2019 before it was officially
announced all of jk got it including
and except for jess because i am
superior and steve thought he was gonna
die like everyone thought they were
gonna die it was like crazy and it
wasn't even around yet because it's
gonna be left without a mother yeah
and then we got diagnosed for bronchitis
i had a fever for like a week and a half
yeah it was nuts and then we got
diagnosed for bronchitis but then 2020 a
year later we got officially diagnosed
with kovid round two and then 2021 i
guess i skipped it i thought i got
omicron after i closed on the house in
vegas but i tested it so it was a
negative number or something yeah it was
right before that was like it was really
spreading quite then yeah but i was in
airports i don't know yeah who knows
yeah but i had all the symptoms i felt
like but uh but yeah i tested negative
um i just was really tested you're
[ __ ] working though yeah i don't know
the rapid test is great because you said
you tested like i just had two false
negatives before i got a positive what's
my sense of smell
left me i was like
this is it like you [ __ ] don't tell
me i don't have it don't [ __ ] guess
like me i know that i have it now
they're like fine you can come in the
club yeah yeah
i was like i just need to be validated
my experience needs to be validated so
i'm telling me i don't have cobin
but the brain fog thing i think it was a
real thing because i would just follow
and space out on words mid-sentence like
i knew what i was trying to tell you it
was it just could not have been a word
because i don't think i've had that and
then now every time i get that i'm like
it was covered it was a coveted after
effect it's a lingerie it's long covered
it's not my fault i never have yeah
brain fog because of you it's not
because of my intelligence
not because you don't know the word for
that thing it's just yeah
i have a vast vocabulary it's just
long covered you know yeah you just
can't reach it i have a big vocabulary
yeah
i have a big
big vocabulary a huge one
it's very big and it's big
well i mean i don't know so i i'm
looking forward to this very short
honeymoon period of not worrying about
anything i'm going to [ __ ] go balls
to the wall in the bars like i'll
probably catch the flu or something else
yeah
but you know other diseases are like oh
yeah
i'm just going to go collect them all
i'm going to get herpes i'm going to get
i'm just going to go collect anything i
can like licking your urinals
i think there's a new variant
no it's that one but another one it's
called
ihu or something and i saw it on
instagram someone commented like damn
now it's the [ __ ] that i hate you by the
way
it's like what the [ __ ] is that the one
from france i don't know oh i don't know
but it's just like there's just so many
variants that like what happened to the
regular flu like the i don't know it's
still going nowhere because people are
getting the flu and krone at the same
time what yeah you can get them at this
you can get it yeah you can get a number
of diseases that you know orgy like yeah
you could get all kinds of stuff i got
you know honestly with the amount of
people i've slept with that probably got
a lot of things floating in my body too
a cocktail of viruses tale of all kinds
of people's bacteria
jesus i'm just kidding don't move to
texas y'all
don't move to austin yeah i'll get you
texas and florida just
anyway
you don't know what you're gonna get
that's so true move to vegas because
it's really safe
sure vegas is the clean place as well
the texans and floridians come to
all the californians that is amazing we
got a lot of new yorkers in texas
actually i would think they would all go
to florida but we did i think we got
half and half like california and new
york are coming to austin i met a lot of
people oh yeah oh there's definitely
californians that moved to vegas but
tourist-wise i was like
texans and floridians for sure people
that don't care
where can we travel cheaply yeah yeah
that's funny
what else is new i freaking love living
in vegas though it's healthy insane i
haven't seen it in person but just the
pictures and the videos like i watched
yeah i feel like a stalker now
i watched your vlog like a the first un
uh decorated oh yeah the like the empty
house
yeah and then i'm just like all the
videos that you've sent me and us in the
group chat and stuff yeah honestly like
i i walk around it and
i'm like this is my dream house yeah i
don't know how to process it yeah
because it's just too much of a good
thing where i'm like i've visualized
something like this for so long you have
it for a year and i'm like i can't
believe i work here losing it because i
feel like when i get something try not
to you really love deep down i'm so
scared yeah deep down i think that's
what it is yeah but i'm trying not to
think that way because those are like
intrusive thoughts and that's like you
don't want to
be a self-fulfilling prophecy exactly
but um yeah it's incredible the house
itself every room i go into i'm like oh
my god i love this room oh my god
the view of the lakes and then the view
of the trees there's so many different
types of trees and then there's just all
they're all the spanish tiling rooftops
it really feels like california is like
the nicest neighborhood i've ever been
to in california but i'm
somehow i can afford to live there in
vegas um and then i also think about how
we almost didn't make an offer on them
[Applause]
like why the [ __ ] are you making this
off i'm like i don't know like the it's
i don't know the floors aren't exactly
like
this
look at this harley davidson inspired
house and i was like oh i think it was
maybe self-sabotage like i didn't feel
like i deserved something like that and
so i was like there's got to be
something wrong with it like
and you're like i don't know if my
energy is lying to this house [ __ ] yeah
just get the [ __ ] house like it's
also murky retrograde i really shouldn't
sign anything and we're getting ready
you in particular should though yeah
because you were born during a mercury
true i was
special good for you i'm born during it
it was true yeah and we bought our condo
during retrograde too and i loved our
condo um and that was the other thing
too is i wasn't sure if i was
emotionally ready like let go of mercano
and then i saw that place and i was like
this is i'm in love like it's like this
is my soul mate house and then walking
around the neighborhood there's like
all these little like peaceful lake
areas that are really private because
you're only you have to have a key to
get in and you're you can only be a
resident to be there and they have like
benches on the water and then ducks swim
up to you and like bunnies are hopping
by and i'm like where am i
there's like a kayaker oh you know
you didn't know like we actually all
died last year yeah yeah
this isn't this is the real life yeah
this is the simulation the simulation
has started yeah wonderful i like the
simulation a lot
um that's what they want you to feel how
you got the premium package it does on
like when i'm trying to process it i was
trying to tell steve like
last year i had this have you guys seen
the movie office space it's kind of old
now yeah okay you guys are in that age
range when chip's not in the age range
yeah
um but office space for those of you who
haven't seen it rented is a good movie
um
go to blockbuster
showing our age i say hour because we
are like the same
well they're in the movie the whole
premise is this guy um then the main guy
he is
mid-hypnosis because like he's getting
hypnotized so he can
quit smoking or something i can't
remember why he's getting hypnotized but
the hypnotist dies in the middle and
this happens in the beginning of the
movie he's not spoiler but he dies in
the middle of the hypnosis and so the
guy is like permanently hypnotized
and he just realizes how much he doesn't
give a [ __ ] about anything yeah and he's
going to his office every day and he's
like why do i give a [ __ ] about any of
this so he just started doing it
actually yeah and so he just starts
doing the things he wants to do like he
just does like what do i really want to
do and that [ __ ] happened to me last
year i think i just was like
what is this like we are in like what
are we even weird
and i just stopped like what's real it
kind of just went like that and then i
was like what if i just we just did
like what we want to do and it feels
good and i think it like led to this
like i'm like i'm how am i living this
like dream life
place and yeah i don't know i'm still
processing it because it feels like i'm
retired
like i wake up and i yeah and i like
what i do for work and then after work i
go play poker and then i like meditate
on a lake and there's bunnies and that's
awesome i really like it a lot you
needed that after you know the last
couple years that you have yeah
yeah difficult you know so
and for like a chronic workaholic like i
really just didn't think
i would be able to not work like i like
to work so much but it also stresses me
out a lot and i just felt like if i ever
stop working i just don't know who i am
like i just don't have an identity if i
don't do you feel like you found a
balance now with work or do you feel
like yes you're able to
like tip even heavier on the other
opposite end
yeah i think that was all that's the
goal and i think i'm getting closer and
closer to it it's not like i don't give
a [ __ ] about anything i do give a [ __ ]
about everything and i gave a [ __ ] too
much about everything and now there's
this balance where it's like no you can
give a [ __ ] and also enjoy life like you
can have that balance of um of just
finding joy in all the things like not
like i have to get this done but like oh
i get to get this done oh i actually
like getting this and i forgot why i did
it in the first place yeah yeah and
that's like the ideal mentality right
that you you get to reframe how you your
perspective on life where it's like i
don't have to do these things i get to
do these things yeah that's totally
something i'm trying to work towards
like just like in general yeah
mentality-wise it's like being more
grateful yeah yeah especially like um in
preparation for birth and like learning
everything that i'm learning
about like in order to have like a
euphoric
natural
birth you really have to euphoric yeah
like you really have a thing you really
have to start from a place of gratitude
yeah it's a thing wait so the pain will
turn to like euphoria yeah like um they
call it the birth high that i've
actually been learning about recently
where it's so [ __ ] fascinating i was
telling nikki about this last night but
there's like um so when you cr when you
have endorphins in your body endorphins
are natural pain blockers right so you
can actually
go through labor without feeling pain
and you can actually because your body
kicks in to cover it
yeah like a door endorphins end up
blocking like anguish or whatever like
pain because at that point you're not
experiencing it because
if you're coming from a place of
gratitude and like openness and like
um happiness
and just like euphoria feeling like you
won't feel like the opposite of that is
being tense being scared being in pain
um and just being like bracing for every
contraction like just being in a really
bad mental space like that that's what
that's really what culturally we've been
fed that labor is like oh my god the
woman screaming she's in so much pain
like the kids ripping her apart like
this is horrible that's why women are so
scared to give birth because that's what
we've been fed culturally and also
that's because of the fact that that's
been fed to us with the media with other
people's stories and the reason why
other people have these stories is
because like it's just they're bracing
for it self-perpetuating yeah exactly
like you're bracing for it you're really
tense you're not prepared you're not
happy you're not in a good place and
when that happens like you're blocking
all those good hormones that make it a
euphoric experience
so
i am i can imagine kind of what you're
saying a little bit because i've seen a
video of a water birth online like
between it was like a husband a wife and
a doula or something we're the only ones
there and she was giving birth in her
tub midwife probably or midwife i don't
know what it is but um yeah and it and
it seemed very almost
romantic and like sensual but not like
in a sexy way but it was just like the
like you could see that he was so
involved with her like he was on the
same like energy yeah vibe as her and
like she was going through it but she
felt
so it looked like she felt so like
released
yeah before the baby had come out she
was already kind of like she had
released some sort of energy and it
seemed very serene and sensual and like
just very beautiful
and i'm like that seems yeah like raw
but like she she was in pain but then
like he was able to comfort her so much
and then like just the whole energy in
the room was just so
relaxed having that safety yeah and say
yeah so i'm like i could see that but
that's not what i normally think of when
i think of giving yeah like how did they
create that space yeah so in order to
even obtain that and that's like the
work that like i'm really doing right
now to prepare for labor
is detaching myself from that fear and
like from other people's stories and
because this is my first
attempt at a natural birth like my
previous birth was a c-section and that
was
like in a sense kind of traumatic like
you know surgery can be traumatic and
also not wanting to have that surgery
yeah and finding out that i was going to
wasn't your choice it wasn't a choice of
mine so that really like made me feel um
what's the opposite of empowered
whatever that is
yeah i have a very vast vocabulary yeah
weak disempowered i don't know
disempowered not empowered
yes if you don't know just put a disc
right on it
on unempowered empowered yeah yeah so i
really so even like having all that in
my own personal experience in my past
like and like just how i didn't have a
great time at the hospital and like how
i've learned about
how the hospital
procedures really set you up for
intervention after intervention after
intervention that leads you to c-section
and then just like finding out about in
the u.s having
like be out of all the first world
countries we have the highest maternal
and infant mortality rate because of
like the practices and like how there's
just like hospitals view
um patients all patients and even
pregnant women as like oh there's a
problem we need to fix it like there's
there needs to be a solution but if
you're perfectly healthy and that's
great if you are in an emergency you
need a hospital like that's perfect
that's exactly what they're trained for
but if you're not at a high risk like
you're not a high-risk pregnancy you're
not there's no complications with your
actual pregnancy than or like even
during your labor there's no reason
to need so many interventions and be
like i need to fix you you're a problem
you know and then that's what ends up
happening there doesn't need to be that
urgency yeah where it's like exactly it
doesn't need to be an emergency like
it's just like let
like the physiological process of birth
happen just like when you take a [ __ ]
like do people tell you like if people
tell you you need to take a [ __ ] right
now you need to push you need to push
really hard and get that [ __ ] out then
you create nothing like those cameras
yeah oh guess what we have a solution
for your hemorrhoids exactly
exactly hand more hands off it's exactly
the way i i see um hospital birth now
and
i just was kind of like factory farming
for babies right like they just do
whatever
they got to do together yeah like okay
we're on a schedule we're gonna induce
you because now you're at 40 weeks even
though there's no medical reason to
induce you it's just that i'm about to
go on vacation
you know things like that when you said
factory farming for babies i pictured
like exactly the whole process of them
like getting the baby out and then they
start milking her
not even they'll get formula like they
won't even respect dude
commercials that are like lawsuits for
hospitals using the wrong baby formula
or something like they're like did you
use such and such did your baby get this
formula while in the hospital call us we
can sue and i'm like oh [ __ ] like
don't give your baby formula i don't
know maybe you're not in the first week
or something i don't know you know i've
talked to if you can i don't know how
yeah if you can i don't know how that
works yeah like i've talked about my
distaste for hospitals and my blogs and
people get offended because they're like
well you know that was your experience
it's like yeah exactly i'm talking about
my experience like i guess i don't
emphasize this enough when i'm talking
about it in my vlogs but it's like if
it's for you and you feel safer at a
hospital go for it because that's the
whole point is like as you're giving
birth like you need to feel safe
protected in a good environment in order
for your body to even like be like oh
body like okay we're good we're safe
baby could come out cool let's get this
baby out because if you're not like in a
hospital setting there's bright lights
there's constantly people checking like
vaginas there's also a ton of sick
people in hospitals and it's like yeah
creepy kinda um yeah and just like that
constant interruption and it interrupts
the natural physiological process of
birth and so that's why they'll end up
having like delayed labor or like
they'll end up having to use forceps or
a balloon or something to get the kid
out because your body's shutting down
and like there's just so many things
that can be completely avoidable if
the system was more respectful of the
natural process of birth and that's
really what i'm learning a lot right now
and
yeah like there's just so much that i've
been absorbing and i'm just really
looking forward to giving birth and
having this experience because like they
really say it's like a rite of passage
for a woman to like experience uh
completely natural uninhibited
um so you're not doing the epidural or
anything like that
well so i'm giving birth at a birth
center okay and they don't offer
epidural there but they do offer
laughing ass if i really wanted some
sort of pain relief but that's what
water is there for like water is a
natural pain relief reliever
and also like breath work and like just
doing a lot of like mental internal work
to trust my body and not have any fear
and like yeah i mean hundreds of years
women didn't have anything so yeah
exactly possible certainly possible yeah
and so like the notion that like our
bodies need help to give birth it's a
little weird completely false like we're
no other species of animal needs yeah we
were designed perfectly like we were
designed perfectly to give birth and
there's no reason for us to ever fear
that our bodies can't do it yeah as soon
as we get that tiny little like
inception of of doubt that's when our
bodies shut down we're like oh [ __ ] yeah
you're right you can't do it yeah it's
almost a little bit placebo it's like if
you think you can you can if you think
you can't you can't right kind of
exactly creates that when it comes to
looking good stitch fix has got you
covered say goodbye to endless browsing
and hello to fresh picks curated for
your taste and size whether you need a
date night dress or cozy loungewear
stitch fix can help refresh your look
you can schedule a fix and a stylist
will send you five pieces that fit your
style size and price range with no
subscription required keep what you like
and return the rest or if you like to
shop but don't want to endlessly browse
then check out stitch fix freestyle it's
an online shop built just for you it's
like having your very own clothing store
to get started take a style quiz so
stitch fix can learn your preferences
from your favorite colors to preferred
fits and price ranges it's the easiest
way to get items that are just right for
you from brands you know and trust like
madewell and sanctuary it's time to get
looks that are so you get started today
by filling out your free style quiz at
stitchfix.com big mood and take
advantage of free shipping and returns
that's stitchfix.com bigmood to try
stitchfix
stitchfix.com
bigmood and we'll be talking about
mindset and mentality uh a lot of your
fitness and health goals have a lot to
do with your mindset if you think in
your head like you can't do it or like
you're weak or you can't go to the gym
or you're not gonna be able to do that
many setups or whatever then you can it
really does affect what your physical
body is capable of so with nume they
really do focus on this psychology-based
approach to help people with their
health and fitness goals as well as
their relationship with food it's
totally different from all the other
programs i've ever tried and it teaches
you how to be just more mindful of the
way that you eat and give you the skills
and knowledge that you need to build
those like long lasting positive habits
so it's not just like a crash diet where
you're like i'm giving up carbs for a
month it's like a long how do you
integrate this is my new lifestyle and
this is just what i do i just am healthy
i just do healthy things i form healthy
habits and breaking those old habits and
you know it's hard to break the habits
that you don't even know you have like
so a lot of these are just like we've
had them for so long they're ingrained
like for me when i was um first trying
new i didn't realize that i snack when i
have anxiety like i don't snack when
like because i want a snack because i'm
hungry i only snack when i'm like
stressed out or only eat brownies at
midnight
that's uh i had to stop
that's definitely i didn't even realize
it it was like a coffee how do you just
have brownies on hand
another reason is not having the
temptation there
yeah so i have to stop ordering
large donut and large things yeah what
puts it in your brain like i need to
order this right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah also social situations because i
get some social anxiety i would always
have to have either a drink in my hand
or a food in my hand or something like
that i'm ingesting just to take away
from yeah like my brain focusing on how
many people i'm interacting with
um so yeah i i feel like it's very
helpful for integrating and they'll give
you different tools to do that they also
have different like um exercises and
stuff that you can do and it's only 10
minutes a day it fits into everyone's
lifestyle on your own terms no grueling
early mornings or large chunks out of
your day you know like someone's like i
gotta go to the gym but man it's gonna
be like a half an hour to get ready and
then driving there and then parking and
then doing the workout then the after no
10 minutes a day you got this start
building better habits for healthier
long term results sign up for your trial
today at noom that's n o o m dot com
slash big mood that's n o o m dot slash
big mood to sign up for your trial today
yay
so i'm really interested in this whole
the natural birth thing my um
sister-in-law was telling you she's on
her third child that she's done this
water birthing way and she goes to a
center and she's super super pro this
way of doing things and it's awesome
she's been trying to tell everybody
about it um whereas like my other
sister-in-law steve's biological sister
is the opposite she's very when you're
like if it's for you it's for you
my other sister-in-law is a vet so she's
a you know phd she's trained in the
medical field and so she's very like i
only feel comfortable at hospitals and
she actually had hemorrhaging her first
birth and she strongly feels that if she
wasn't in the hospital that it could
have gone a different way yeah because
she was losing so much blood and they
had to fix it within five minutes and so
i get both sides like it's a scary thing
either way you have to feel really
comfortable because that's the key yeah
and my sister-in-law that had the
hemorrhaging that happened before the
other sister-in-law had her first child
so i was asking her i was like i was
like are you still planning on doing
like a natural birth because like this
really scary thing happened like we were
all praying for
her and everything and um and uh the the
second sister-in-law was like no i just
in my heart like this is for me um
whatever happens happens but i really
truly feel like
either way i want it i want to do it
this way and also good for you tiff has
always been like very okay with dying
i'm not afraid at all just not afraid of
you know
the reaper
she's like she wants to go out her own
way
you know so if it's meant to happen i
feel like you're okay with it that's
yeah that definitely helps is part of it
the fact that i'm okay with it but also
like casey and i we took this birth
course it's like an online birth course
from this chick that i follow on
instagram and highly recommend it it's
called pain free birth is her instagram
account and that's where i learned a lot
of this stuff where i'm like oh my god
yeah like we're fed so many lies like
culturally about birthing and stuff but
anyway in this course
the very first thing that she unpacks is
like like what's in your bag like your
your bag of fears around birth and like
let's like write it out like she had me
do like a whole list of all my fears
that i'm um worried about with birth
and she's like okay now like take those
fears and realize like that's not your
story that's not that doesn't have to
continue to be your story if it was in
your past and it doesn't have to be your
story if it's someone else's that you're
carrying inside your bag and so you just
let it go you go like that's uh i forgot
her phrase but it's something about like
well that was their story but it's not
gonna be mine yeah and like you just
detach yourself from it and it's like
that's really where it starts it's like
your your mental preparation to not
be afraid is the biggest key and if
you're gonna be afraid
giving birth at home or giving birth at
a birth center or anywhere else that's
not a hospital then the hospital's for
you like go to the hospital gonna make
it like you know where your anxiety is
yeah is guiding you like in this
direction or this direction like you
seem to have more anxiety being in the
hospital yes i actually that is my my
story my story is i want everything in
my power to stay out of a hospital like
i really do not want to also that's your
that's your truth and that's your choice
that doesn't mean that that's a general
truth so i don't understand why people
would like to be able to buy your own
people get really attached to their
beliefs as if it's part of their
identity and when you have a opposing
belief even if it's true to you it's
like somehow an attack on them and they
probably don't even know consciously why
they feel so offended but it really is
this is for every subject like when you
have a belief that has you've attached
to your identity is when you start like
getting super defensive
if people have another opinion yeah and
so it's important to check yourself if
that's
something that you've been judging other
people on lately just because they have
a different opinion than you know it's
probably something to do with you for
sure attaching your identity to that
belief that's true but yeah and like um
the the craziest thing though about this
whole
thing about me preparing for birth and
stuff was the fact that
i so i started off my pregnancy with
going to a doctor like my regular doctor
my ob that i would go get my pap smears
with every couple years or whatever
that's where i started my pregnancy and
then i started asking her questions
after learning a lot from that instagram
account and i'm like oh yeah i should
ask my doctor like what are her thoughts
on this like what is her c-section rate
and like what like how many checks is
she gonna give me like am i gonna have a
fetal monitor on me that am i gonna be
able to move like all these like things
that i wanted to know about the birth so
i started asking her these questions and
it was just like red flag after red flag
after red flag where like she she got
defensive every time i asked her
something she's like you know you don't
have to be here if you don't want to i'm
like girl i'm not even okay attacking
you yeah yeah i was just like it's a
genuine question like what is your
c-section rate and she was like i don't
know it's like whatever the hospitals is
like i don't i don't really know i'm
like you know how many c-sections you've
done in this past month and she goes
yeah no it's the hospital standard like
whatever that i'm like all right i'm out
of here she got scared to answer those
questions yeah she got really um yeah
really nervous and like i said really
defensive and also the way she even came
in too where it's like
oh my god i can't wait next week i'm
going on vacation and like she's just
really like not really i was like this
is a different doctor that i knew during
my checkups like before like she gave me
vibes that she really cared like she was
really like before you were pregnant
yeah before i was pregnant okay like
really like invested in listening to my
questions and answering them like
thoroughly like completely different
care that i got
um but then once i got pregnant like
yeah like she switched her tune and i
was like okay i'm out of here like yeah
i don't maybe it doesn't have anything
to do with that maybe just like i feel
like a lot of medical professionals now
too are starting to get exhausted
and like just like because then they
have like
people fighting you know vaccinations
like there's all kinds of stuff that
they're fighting with
constantly yeah so definitely maybe it's
not like you or like no yeah i'm not
even seeing i'm not even saying that
either yeah she just in general wouldn't
want to be taking care of that
her mindset towards her job maybe is not
like in a place that makes you feel
comfortable right now yeah and then so
this particular clinic though too like
every time we'd go
like i'd be there like earlier than my
call like uh what is it appointment time
like 10 minutes no call time like
earlier than my appointment
like 10 minutes before my appointment
time or whatever or sometimes like on my
appointment time and they still make me
wait a whole hour before seeing the
doctor so i'm like this office is a mess
yeah it's just a lot of things right
anyway that was my experience in the
beginning of this pregnancy so i
switched over to a birth center and this
birth center i had been having an eye on
since like 2017 i'm like oh this is
where i want to go like once we start
getting pregnant because around that
time was when we got married and i was
like oh yeah like next year we're going
to start trying to get pregnant like
where do i want i definitely don't want
to give birth to hospital even back then
i already knew and so i found this birth
center and i'm like cool it's in
pasadena like i definitely want to birth
here
after my ob i switch over i'm there for
two months
and then they send an email and they say
we're shutting down in two weeks
in two weeks you need to like within two
weeks you need to find another care
provider because we're literally
shutting down our entire business
where i was like what the [ __ ] and
yeah that was really stressful and
luckily like i'm still like you know i
still have a lot of time so i just felt
so bad for the parents that like were
even like closer to their due date
because they were like yeah like there's
these rumors about how like the business
side of that burst center got really
shady like
i don't know there's rumors that they
pretty much puts like the husband of the
wife or the owner or whatever is a
lawyer and like put things into place to
like make sure that the clients don't
get their full money back and that's a
fact because
out of the money that we get we were
giving payments because it's like one
full fee for this birth center we were
giving payments and like i said i only
went there for two months
and
that amount of money that i gave we only
got like a tiny bit back and like they
charged us like so much per visit where
i'm like this is
shady as hell so
dealing with that whole birth center
thing i'm like oh my god i have like two
months before i get birthdays i need
another place from the scam that the
medical system is oh i mean there you
it's like 30 thousand dollars for for
you to be in the hospital for a day or
something and give a baby it's like
what is costing 30 000
yeah
insurance
yeah with insurance yeah it's all a scam
yeah so that other birth center going
there i was already like
even though i really wanted to come here
they weren't gonna let me give birth at
the birth center because i'm having a v
back which is called a vaginal birth
after caesarean
so
like i'm considered like a little bit
more high risk because like there is
like there's literally one percent a one
percent chance
of my scar bursting open like and then
causing crazy complications and
so that's the reason why like some
places would be like oh no you should
just not give birth here like you're not
the best candidate so that was the case
with this personality reliability
reasons yeah they were gonna have me
birth like i was getting my care with
the midwife at the birth center but to
birth i was going to still have to birth
out a hospital and i was really bummed
about that because i'm like uh like i
really didn't want to birth at a
hospital but
at least they'll be under midwife care
like maybe i can like still try to
implement things that i would like
either at home or at the birth center
like low lights or whatever it is so
anyway so then that burst that are
shutting down was actually a blessing in
disguise because then they luckily they
sent us a list of providers that would
be willing to take
patients from our clients from that
birth center so i found this other birth
center and this one is like
the gold standard like so
much better than the one that i was
previously with like
going to these midwives like they made
me feel so
like whole like a whole
person like a whole patient like they
actually treated you like they treated
an individual human being yeah like with
so much respect too which like this
might sound excessive but every time
before she touched me she was like i'm
gonna touch you is that okay like she
asked me for every time and i'm like oh
my god they made a big impact on me
because i'm like
to be you're not treated like cattle
yeah like to be treated with respect i
don't know i'm getting emotional
i'm gonna touch you is that okay
yeah like
i didn't even cry when i talked about
this before but yeah yeah like do you
feel like you've never really gotten
that level of respect
no
not in like as a patient yeah sorry okay
you got a lot of hormones you're
laughing yeah yeah yeah we're gonna play
with the hormones if you didn't cry i
would wonder if the baby was healthy
because there was no chemicals in there
so funny i can't believe i'm crying um
it makes sense yeah because like when
you've experienced kind of a
cold and traumatic feeling from a
hospital and then to go into something
that's kind of like a hospital but to
get
that level of personal attention and to
be told like you don't have to be here
if you don't want to and yeah
because
was in the same office as my old ob but
i had a male and he was always very
sweet and kind to me so i was like maybe
try my doctor but you're like i'm
already sick of this office
a lot of the trauma that i've had um
comes from the experience of me giving
birth to isaac because i was 17 back
then too like they didn't respect me
like they didn't course not they didn't
listen to me i
kept telling them like i think my baby's
upside like breached and they wouldn't
listen until
i did like i finally asked for an
ultrasound and the only reason why i got
that ultrasound was because isaac's aunt
was a medical assistant to my ob like it
was literally like the stars had a line
for us to find out that he was breech
and that's what led to the c-section so
yeah like i definitely
don't ever i can i had never felt
respected as you know as a patient yeah
i'm
going to this per center
um
it just yeah like i'm really happy that
i get to be with these men why you found
that place yeah be able to birth there
too so i'm really excited i'm so happy
for you yeah
so it really it feels like you found the
match you know like and it was scary too
even after i got like
like trying to get into this new birth
center i'm like oh my god i don't know
if they're going to take me because they
only take a certain amount of patience
um just so they don't have like an
overflow whatever you can care so they
can do their job yeah exactly
so i'm like [ __ ] like i don't know if
they'll even accept me finally we got
accepted and
i had a nightmare like after getting
accepted after going to my first
appointment like okay cool like i'm safe
here we go
that night or like in that week i had a
nightmare that my midwife like changed
her tune and she started being mean to
me and like she just started to like
change things and like was being so rude
and disrespectful and i'm like well what
happened and then and then like the the
owner of the birth center was like hey
i'm sorry like you know you're gonna
have to find somewhere else and i'm like
wow
did you wake up crying
i almost did yeah i almost did i i
didn't i was crying in my in my dream
but not in real life that's so funny
like that same [ __ ] i wonder if it just
you know because they say your dreams
are your biggest fears and anxieties or
the or like your wishes and wants
um when steve and i first started dating
and i was like dude i really think this
guy's my soul mate and he was like the
best [ __ ] ever um
i would have dreams nightmares of him
just like being cold and mean all of a
sudden and him like going back to his ex
or like him being like what i don't love
you like i don't i don't even care about
you like and and just being so mean yeah
and i would wake up crying like
because he i thought i felt like the
perfect person and then yeah i think and
then you found the perfect thing and
you're dreaming about her being like no
you're not welcome yeah it's not like we
don't like you
yeah it's so funny i guess it's like our
our subconscious being like all right so
we finally got the thing we wanted yeah
like prepare you still work it away just
in case just like you were talking about
about like getting scared of losing it
yeah you find something so perfect and
you're like please please let me keep it
it's almost like you don't believe that
you're allowed to have it yeah right
yeah yeah that's a whole other issue we
should unpack some episode
because yeah i feel like all of us have
that in in a way yeah i think so yeah
and it's good i mean i feel happy
hearing so even though there's been
struggle in your story it's almost like
you guys struggle to get pregnant for so
long like you know there's just a lot of
issues happening and then
now like it's finally it's almost like
it was so like it was supposed to happen
the way it did like you're supposed to
wind up here on the day that you do
and so like the fact that it wasn't
working before at the time you're just
like oh this is [ __ ] i don't know you
know like but now it's like it kind of
makes sense like things may be needed
yeah the time that they
needed to happen yeah the writers put a
good arc in the scene they did they were
really good yeah
so we weren't sure what was gonna happen
is she gonna have to give birth in a
hospital yeah
weren't sure
and you got pushed into the gold
standard place yeah
i'm really happy now you get to have the
sensual experience you always wanted in
the birth center we're not we're not
making the birth center sexy
but we do have a sexy ad
for you guys out there you guys and gals
uh it's dipsy which is an audio app for
sexy stories
i know we like to do a sexy voice but i
don't really have it do it
you can try i can pretend
but my voice is still kind of my
throat's even better scratchy okay
sometimes doing less can lead to
something okay never mind
stories no okay dipsy stories believes
in less
i can't do it i love it every time i
tried doing the dipsy ad and the sexy
voice i can only do like two sentences
about that story
it's about the incl it's like the
reflections stories yeah there you go
believes in less analyzing and more
feeling your feelings less stressing and
more easing into things okay
it's someone's kink yes scrolling and
more savoring the moment
go british
you're in for a ride okay
less pressure and more pleasure
why do i'm in a library
i don't know what happened dipsy stories
is an app full of sexy audio stories and
they now even have brand new written
stories no matter who you're into or
what turns you on dipsy helps bring the
stories to life anytime anywhere just
close your eyes and let yourself get
lost in a world
where only good things happen that's a
dramatic pleasure is your only priority
explore your fantasies in a safe
shame-free way there are hundreds of
stories to choose from
and they release new content every week
so there's always more to explore they
also have wellness sessions to help you
wind down and explore the sleep sessions
to help you drift off for our listeners
dipsy is offering an extended 30-day
free trial when you go to
dipsystories.com
mood make sure to use our code that's 30
days full access for free when you go to
dipsy
d-i-p-s-e-a stories dot com slash mood
dipsy stories dot com slash mood and um
while you're listening to these stories
you want to make sure you have a nice
healthy body
to yeah to enjoy that stuff with and
that's where ritual comes in
so we deserve to know what we're putting
in our bodies and why especially when it
comes to something that we take every
single day
gaps in the diet shouldn't be ignored
because over 97 of women aged 19 to 50
are not getting enough vitamin d from
their diet and 95 are not getting their
recommended daily intake of ketomega
threes can i get that d
rituals essential for women 18 and over
multivitamin was formulated by
exhaustive research to help fill
nutrient gaps
in the diets of women ages 18 and over
it is formulated with nutrients to help
support brain health bone health blood
health and provide antioxidant support i
personally love ritual i've been taking
their prenatal for like over a year and
a half or maybe even two years now i
really
a long time i absolutely love it and
i've taken other prenatals in the past
and
those like ah they're really gross and
you yeah it's a larp
yes the vitamin burp that you could
taste like the fish oil yeah
i never once ever have gotten that with
ritual and i my pee doesn't come out
bright like yellow like my body's
actually absorbing all the nutrients
that ritual has i'm a huge fan i love it
so much that i even got um vitamins for
my sons because they also have like
vitamins for teens
so i'm a huge fan i absolutely recommend
ritual and ritual is offering our
listeners 10 off during your first three
months visit ritual.com big mood and
turn healthy habits into a ritual that's
10 off ritual.com
big mood ritual.com
big mood yeah so
i can't believe i got emotional there
but i'm glad you did yeah like i don't
know it just it really has been a
journey
it's good to recognize when
good things happen too so like even if
it makes you emotional and it's
embarrassing it's like it's tears of
relief and gratitude and yeah yeah
because like you recognize that you have
beautiful support i really love too like
how at this birth center like the first
the first appointment is um minimum like
an hour long so she we went through like
my whole history but also
she really wanted to um touch base on my
emotional state too like how i'm feeling
about giving birth like how i'm feeling
during pregnancy like what trauma how do
i have that might come up during birth
because like they really say like while
you're in labor and you're giving birth
like there's a lot of things that come
up if you don't deal with it during
pregnancy like you're gonna have to deal
with it then and so yeah like bringing
up the fact that i've i've had past
trauma like she's she recommended a
therapist and like just really treating
me as a whole person so i'm like oh my
god it's not just about the baby that's
like in your uterus she's like i need to
make sure you're okay yeah
yeah and that's the beauty about me
lives too that i've been learning a lot
about like their whole
approach um to care for
like prenatal care it really is that
it's like dealing with the whole person
because they they know
mental like your psycho your psychology
going into birth plays a huge role
because if you don't feel safe if you
feel like scared or if you feel like
whatever you feel that's gonna affect
how you're bringing out this kid yeah
and like it will stall labor if you're
not feeling safe or whatever yeah so i
don't know it's been really it's been
really interesting just learning a lot
and preparing myself for this big event
that's gonna be coming really soon
because now i'm 33 weeks so
seven more weeks
what oh and by the time this comes out
oh yeah but it'll be like i think this
comes out in the week of like the week
before i'm due oh my god
so it's crazy
are you like how are you feeling in
general are you like really excited or
like super excited are you do you feel
prepared i feel
like not just the birth but for like the
the new parenthood journey yeah that
part um that part i'm unpacking still a
little bit yeah one thing at a time yeah
yeah cause um yeah right now like my
sole focus is like preparing for birth
and like okay we can do this body we got
this you're so strong already carrying
this baby and like just doing all these
things right so that's like been most of
my energy's been focused on the labor
like the birth but like really thinking
about like bringing in a new kid into
our lives and like getting to know this
personality and like raising a whole
another person and like you got stuff to
do now every minute of the day you've
got someone that you have to take care
of
all over again yeah like we recently had
our baby shower so like we were
unpacking like doing all the presents
and stuff and like i washed all the
bottles like washing all the blankets
and everything and i'm like figuring out
where to put them and like thinking of a
system of like how to like just things
like organizing and then be thinking
like oh my god i'm i'm gonna have like a
kid yeah to like do these things with
and like
and feed and like change their diaper
and like
just so many things and then i'm
thinking about all this but a lot of it
too um that comes with these thoughts is
like and i'm gonna get to do that with
casey and like i get to like show casey
a lot of the things that i've already
learned that he's gonna be learning and
like doing this together and like and
then thinking about like having isaac
around in the house and
thinking of ways of like how to make him
feel involved but not overwhelmed and
like not neglected and like
yeah there's just there's a lot there's
a lot having a teenager and a newborn at
the same time has got to be like
a wild time as a parent
we'll see because those are supposedly
like the hardest
times yeah exactly you are gonna be on
very little sleep
and then you have a teenager
i know he's like peak teenager right now
too do you think he's gonna try to get
close to the baby or do you think he's
gonna do that like uh whatever like it's
not really my deal i'm going to college
now like i'm not going to he's already
doing the second the ladder like i'm not
i don't give a [ __ ] about this kid yeah
he's already like yeah i'm going to move
out it's your second week it's your kid
now like i'm gone peace out yeah he
really is
with that attitude and maybe he'll come
back around in like five years once the
kid just kind of has a little bit more
of a personality and he'll get yeah and
if the kid like looks up to him i think
that will change hopefully they can be
somewhat close in some way yeah that's
what i'm really hoping if it's like an
uncle vibe you know yeah i'm really
hoping for that for something like some
sort of like connection and or bonding
and like throughout the pregnancy like
whenever the baby's kicking or something
like oh isaac let me get your hand and
he's like okay whatever
and then there was this one time where i
mean i'm also like hormonal right so
we're dealing with two very hormonal
people like there was this one day where
i was just like you know what i gotta
like i gotta get this off my chest and
i'm like isaac like i just it really
hurts me that you don't you don't really
wanna connect with this baby yeah or
like it hurts my feelings that you know
you're you're really avoidant or
whatever like we had a conversation
about it and he was so sweet he was just
like okay mom i'm sorry like i'm gonna
try and you know and then the next
opportunity he comes up to me and like
or he was saying good night that night
and he like gives me a hug and then he
goes good night baby and then he tries
to talk to the baby and i'm like oh
you're such a good kid that's sweet yeah
he he
received what i said and like he put it
into usually you just have to tell
people what's in your head because they
don't really know like what you need
yeah
you just tell people what you need uh
yeah but for a 13 year old like that's
impressive yeah you're responding
quickly yeah yeah i'm like dude yeah i'm
so proud of him like instead of being
like oh whatever like why are you so
upset yeah exactly yeah yeah well so
that just goes to show that you did a
good job yeah just fight despite you
know being like a teen mom and all the
[ __ ] you were going through for that so
then imagine how good yeah despite being
now such a growth yeah
despite his teenager hormones he still
has the good upbringing in him yeah yeah
that's true yeah
that's i'm excited what about you jess
what you've been doing in texas besides
getting on micron absolutely [ __ ] off
we were like okay we're gonna have a
meeting for big moon and she's like oh i
can't make it i have a company
volleyball
game
what is happening company volleyball
yeah
yeah it was cold as [ __ ] dude let me
tell you i don't know whose [ __ ] idea
was to jo to join a volleyball an
outdoor sand volleyball
running from december through january
yeah
but yeah so the cheapest your
accountants are like okay this is for
the budget
no our company's paying for it so it
doesn't matter it's just it's year-round
so they don't expect anything to really
be that cold but it's been cold yeah i
don't know what the [ __ ]
but yeah it's just this sports league
that runs 24 7 basically there's always
like a league of something but our our
company like there's just like the
sports guy right like there was a guy
that like did play baseball in college
and so like he's the one that goes
around the office like hey do you guys
want to join a league and like
and they they had a golf one too or
something and then this guy like they
they won and so it's just like something
that you can brag about in the office to
to make the managers notice you like oh
you're creating team building activities
and so i'm like i'm in one of those you
know like i'm just doing things to like
be involved getting credit yeah getting
some social credit extra credit yeah you
know like um that that never stopped
good for you though like yeah personally
and also just to get and it only takes
like an hour out of my day i go to their
thing we play like it's like best two
out of three and then the last the one
we lost it was [ __ ] cold though i
mean yeah
i was like i don't give a [ __ ] get me
out of here um but yeah it's just it's
really quick it takes like an hour but
then you're like building rapport with
your co-workers and you just like get to
do extra things i think in the
summertime you're gonna wear those
little volleyball shorts
well i need to get back into this boss
and notice you yeah i'm in the bible
no uh i don't need my box my boss is
sexualizing me um no no you're just
noticing your volleyball skills noticing
my skills yeah keep keep me around for
my skills yeah okay
yeah now so um yeah i've just i don't
know i've just been working and then
i've been hating on my dad a lot i've
been going on a lot of dates that have
still not really gone anywhere what's
the indiana jones update oh yeah i
forgot so i haven't been here since
november yeah it's november when we last
saw each other so i wound up waiting
like a month or something and then i
like reached out to the girl that's like
the mid person that knows him or
whatever and i was like yo can i get his
number i'm kind of like not interested
in dating him but like we had a good
night so i i kind of have room for
another good night yeah i mean like i
realize that i don't i really honestly
don't want a relationship right now like
i just don't i'm just trying to get my
myself together still so but i do enjoy
like going out getting drunk maybe
dancing or doing something fun and then
having sex and then like then i can just
focus again on work on monday not like
is he going to call me are you going to
start a relationship is my whole life
going to change do i need to [ __ ]
make room for this person it's like part
of your r r schedule yeah it's like i
just i and that's when i actually enjoy
men the most
is when i'm drunk and we're dancing and
having fun we're good for two weeks
i don't want to hear your [ __ ] [ __ ]
on a tuesday morning um so
so that's kind of what's working for me
right now i've seen him like two more
times or something but then also like
that like long periods of time will go
between us even speaking and i'm like
totally okay with it there's not really
like we did go to a dinner we did have
dinner and then we went out again one
night and just like talking and stuff
and i'm like yeah there's not really
like a yeah it gives some time to
explore temples and find holy grails and
stuff yeah
he's very busy yeah raiding dooms
temples and doing reading yeah yeah
he's very busy with other yeah but no i
and i've been to his house he's like
remodeling a house it's like a duplex
that he's remodeling to like rent out
and all this stuff and like he was just
like what do you think should i buy
these [ __ ] blood you know like this
[ __ ]
and i'm like yeah sure whatever
so yeah i'm just um i
i do foresee a future i'm like i hope at
some point i could find somebody to love
and like keep them around as a companion
like 24 7 i don't necessarily want to
always just be like meeting new guys or
whatever but like for now as i'm going
into we're gonna have a busy season
which means i'm gonna work 55 hours a
week holy [ __ ] from january through may
is that including volleyball or like
that on top of
so it's like i know i don't i can't give
someone the time of day even really it's
like i can see you on a saturday night
yeah and then i could say goodbye to you
sunday morning and then i have to get
back to work and that's just kind of
where i'm at right now and i'm okay with
it i feel good about that i feel good
about like just working a lot and kind
of getting because i feel like i spent a
lot of my time in my last relationship
supporting him and his career goals and
stuff and i was just kind of like one
lost yourself i kind of lost myself i
didn't really set myself up for my own
future so now i'm kind of making up for
lost time everyone else is kind of on
i'm going to work less tip right now
which thank god
you know applause to the rest of the
world because i think a lot of people
needed that that's me on the lake i'm
like yeah yeah yeah but for me like i
feel like i had already like retired for
six years yeah i had this long break and
now i'm like
you're like oh okay
yeah yeah thank you set myself up for
security so yeah i'm just [ __ ]
looking at zillow every weekend i'm like
making a plan
hopefully by the time i come back i
think we're not filming again together
or me yeah i'm skipping i'm going to be
skipping a couple future filming
episodes but i am coming back in may and
i'm hoping by then i'll kind of have
like something to say
about all right what i'm going to be
buying in austin so we'll see where i am
with that at that point because my lease
is up in may yeah i think both of these
things have been really good for you
because again it's all about finding
balance you know if you're too much one
way or the other then you're going to
feel stressed and unbalanced as a person
not happy and i think that before when
you
like you did you hadn't started work
again like a like a nine to five
schedule and you
wanted a relationship and yeah there was
a lot of pressure on like the next guy
has to be like husband material yeah it
was just a lot of pressure and so when
it doesn't happen it's like oh now back
to this like
nothingness and um and then friendships
and social circles everything seemed
like kind of like off the table um and
then now you're kind of it's like
training wheels like you got integrated
back into
having a balanced life you got your work
going on you got some extra curricular
activities where you're socializing yeah
you've got extra
secular activities
i try to make it work but i don't know
extracurriculars
got there um yeah and then
you're you're not putting the pressure
on like the relationship aspect and you
have your own goals outside of a
relationship is like i'm going to buy a
house and yeah it's really healthy yeah
i think it's super healthy i sort of
feel like i need to do everything alone
and then bring someone in i don't know
why i'm just kind of like i really just
wanted
i want to get my healthy as well yes
yeah i want to get my own spot i want to
feel like totally and i'm just so used
to being alone now that i'm like
imagining
like having someone in my house like
during the week and in my head i'm like
what the [ __ ] like you don't belong
you know so i don't know i just kind of
like the idea and some people will
probably be like oh well you know you're
going to get old and ugly and you can't
do that forever but i'm like yeah
they're just projecting i'm like if
you're happy because if i have the money
i could probably keep it nice and tight
and yeah still be pulling in my 50s and
60s so i may not even really need to go
to the marriage route my cousin is the
same i have a cousin in austin she's in
her 40s and she's got her own house and
everything in her own job and she like
dare be used by herself in the backyard
yeah that's cute she'll like have all
the cousins over i've got a lot of
cousins in that age range like the 40s
age range and then so i finally started
getting invited to the little barbecues
and stuff and i'm like the spinster life
is fine like she's chilling she has no
[ __ ] issues like that's why i don't
understand how people can't understand
that
that people
find happiness in different things yeah
like maybe for some people they really
like having kids and have a family life
and for other people maybe they really i
just don't know if i have a personality
for you
and how come both can't be happy why
why is it like you have to do it the way
that i find happiness yeah i find
happiness this way so all people must
find happiness once i realized so like i
always heard that thing well
what what scared me the most in my life
was like i don't want to die alone right
like that's where i'm like to a certain
point i'll be cool but then it's going
to get sad right you're gonna die then
i'm like how many women do i know that
are like in their late 60s early 70s
their husbands have already died their
kids [ __ ] off they don't [ __ ] never
come see them anyway
and then they're just like kind of alone
trying to find social groups or they
wind up in a nursing home and they're
still alone so like having a family or a
husband or something throughout your
life doesn't guarantee that at the end
of your life you're even going to have
[ __ ] that's true so that's not the
reason to do those things like if that's
your reason to do those things then you
could wind up with nothing anyway
that was honestly my
only reason i was like i need to have
kids there someone's got to figure out
what to do with me i need to have a
husband so and i'm like that
[ __ ] probably going to die of a
heart attack before i do so
if that that really was my only
reasoning i was like at the end of my
life i'm worried about what that's gonna
look like but now i'm kind of like i'll
just [ __ ] take myself out like if it
gets that sad i'll just go out like
yo i believe in that like um you know
it's very controversial the planned
suicide thing that's what i'm thinking i
i believe like if i move at a certain
age where i'm like i can't even i don't
have my mental there i don't have my
physical there someone has to wear my
ass yeah
they made
it takes out all of the oxygen and it
puts all the nitrogen in and then you
just kind of like euphoric for a minute
and then you're just [ __ ] dead so
down yeah so i'm like man like we've got
another 30 40 years so there should
hopefully be like suicidal centers maybe
suicide robots suicide pods centers
suicide centers
suicide wellness
and then even if you yes it's like goop
right so even if you like get like for
me in my life i'm just thinking like oh
that kind of sort of makes things like
even better because like i don't even
have to worry that much about saving for
retirement like i can just make money
kind of spend a lot of it as i go
because then like what people are
waiting for people are mostly saving
like a million dollars or two million
dollars to either pass it on or stop
working at some point and then have
money to live on right but i'm like i
could just [ __ ] ball out for the rest
of my life i don't have to give it to
anyone and then when i run out it's just
like i'm 55 yeah
i'm so scared of walking and i have no
money left i'll just [ __ ] bounce like
why do i need to work one way to get to
the table
don't call so that's my point i told my
friend this my friend that's in austin
and she was like
i don't i don't like what you're saying
to me right now i was just like no this
is a good thing like i'm happy about my
facial expressions
this is a good thing
no i'm actually like because i've been
depressed for a lot of like my 20s and
then like what the [ __ ] am i doing in my
30s look at the one thing that excites
her is death now it really is no no but
i mean i'm seeing that out you know like
i'm 30 i'll be 35 in june so i'm
imagining that i have 45 85 65 maybe a
good 30 years because after 75 you know
after 70 is questionable it's
questionable my dad's 68 and he's in
good health so it's not like i'm gonna
be decrepit at 75 but like i imagine
there's not too much left after 75 to 85
to 95 it's like it's you know
a lot right now but i think it's just
because i want to be able to pay for a
lot of [ __ ] while i'm young and alive
and like i wonder how expensive this is
like
well i'm ready for that
yeah i have to pay for it it's gonna be
the one thing i'm so i'm not saving for
a retirement where i'm gonna be in a
boat for [ __ ]
three years you know like i'm gonna stay
for the suicide pod because it'll just
be easier to go out
and on that note yeah
we are done with the this episode the
second subscribe and like make sure you
find out what happens yes on these
titillating journeys yes
mine is still a long journey don't worry
i'm not trying to go yeah you gotta
watch for a long time yeah subscribe be
a long time subscriber so you get the
arc um anyway good job on the set tiff
and uh um
i know it's beautiful check out their
vlogs tune in next week we'll talk about
the set
yeah cliffhanger sure sure yeah
uh subscribe follow us on instagram we
ask you for prompts and actually one of
the upcoming episodes it has to do with
that so tune in and i will see you next
week bye
[Music]
you